The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Where we left it at
the end of last time was the
mechanism for poverty trap
that [INAUDIBLE]
explained, and that was kind of
a workhorse of development
economics for many years,
since the 1950s, might
actually, surprisingly,
not be at play.
In that, number one, the
effect of your calorie
consumption on your productivity
in the immediate
next few days is probably
not large enough.
And, perhaps as a consequence,
or perhaps just because they
have other things to do with
their money, we don't see the
poor also consuming as
much as they can.
And therefore, we don't see a
very high elasticity of food
consumption with respect
to wages.
So if we don't have a very high
elasticity of wages with
respect to consumption, and
we don't have a very high
elasticity of consumption with
respect to wages, then we are
not going to get a very highest
elasticity of wages
tomorrow with respect
to wages yesterday.
And therefore, the whole thing
of I am poor because I am
poor, based on how much
food I can consume
is not really there.
So on the one hand, you could
say fine, that great.
It means we can start focusing
on other programs, and
nutrition is not really
an issue.
And for some people, that
has been the conclusion.
For example, on Tuesday, we
showed some graphs coming from
the paper by Angus Deaton and
Jean Dreze about the fact that
people are consuming less and
less calories in India.
So they are becoming richer, so
they are moving along the
angle curve.
And that would make
them consume more,
everything else equal.
But the thing is, not everything
else is equal.
And at the same time, we
have the angle of curve
shifting to the right.
So that it's a swimming upstream
movement, where
you're trying to go up the angle
curve, but the angle
curve is shifting right, so you
end up actually consuming
less, fewer calories than you
would otherwise consume,
So for some people in India,
this is a sign that there's
much more poverty than
the official
statistics are saying.
Because if we define poverty as
not having enough to eat,
then we have more and more
people who in fact don't have
enough to eat.
But what is strange is that if
we look at the other things
that people consume, and we
measure poverty in this way,
which is, if you look at the
entire budget, are you below--
are you someone who consumes
less than a dollar a day per
capita, of 16 rupees a day,
because it's India?
And you don't find that.
You find that actually there are
fewer and fewer people who
are below a dollar a day.
There is still a number.
It's about 13%.
but it's certainly going down.
So it has to be that people
exercise a choice
not to eat as much.
So Deaton and Dreze who wrote
this paper and documented the
decline in calorie consumption
in India, have one
explanation.
And their explanation is that
people's need for calories has
gone down because they are
less ill, they have fewer
children, they are doing less
intense physical work.
A lot of people have moved
to the urban areas.
So it's just they eat
less because they
need less of the strength.
And therefore we have nothing
to worry about, in a sense.
The fact that people are eating
less is, in a sense, a
sign of success of India's
economic growth.
But if it were the case, then
we should find that the
nutritional status of people
would be adequate.
Defined in more objective
terms.
Not the calories you're
consuming, but what is your
weight, what is your height.
Whether you're anemic or not.
We should find an improvement
in that.
Because, to the extent that
people are getting richer,
they should want a little bit
of improvement in their
nutritional status.
And what is striking and
surprising, which is why they
might be hidden traps is that
by all accounts, in India in
particular but in other places
as well, people are still not
very well-nourished.
And it is more a matter
of there is some
undernourishment, which is
people are not eating that
many calories.
And also, maybe something that
people referred to as hidden
hunger, and you can think
about as malnutrition.
Which is even the condition of
having enough calories if
people are not getting enough
of the other micronutrients
that they need-- for
example, anemia.
So here is a number for India.
33% of men and 36% of women
have a BMI below 18.5.
And meanwhile, iron deficiency
anemia affects maybe something
like a billion people
worldwide.
And iron deficiency anemia means
that people are in fact
less strong, because the ability
of their body or their
blood to process the
oxygen is limited.
Because we process the oxygen
with other blood cells in our
body, the hemoglobin
in our blood.
And if we don't have enough of
that, we're not very good at
processing the oxygen.
So you put people on the
treadmill that are anemic, and
they are not able to
make it go as far.
So we have here a puzzle that,
on the one hand, we don't see
people appearing to be
hungry for calories.
In fact, in China we see this
Jensen, Miller evidence, which
goes the opposite way.
Which is, you make the cheaper
source of calories cheaper,
and people eat fewer calories,
at least in one region.
And yet, they seem to be not
very well-nourished.
so what could be going on?
Let me start with you,
your reason.
And I will present it.
AUDIENCE: Their diets are
very narrow and the
same all the time.
So they don't really correlate
what they eat to--
It's just kind of an
informational thing.
They don't realize what kinds
of nutrients they actually
need, so they just have what
tastes good or what they're
used to eating.
PROFESSOR: So it could
be, for example--
I'm just rephrasing for
everyone, because you speak in
this very nice and soft tone--
It could be that they don't
have the information that
nutrition affects
your strength.
In fact, you proposed one very
specific theory for that,
which is, if you've never
experimented because you've
always eaten same thing, then
you might not know what would
happen outside of your
normal range.
So that would be one reason
why you don't have the
information.
AUDIENCE: And then when
someone, or maybe the
government, suggests a different
diet, or replacing
what people are normally used to
eating, they're not really
willing to take that advice.
And so that can--
they'll just continue
eating [INAUDIBLE]
just normally eating.
Their diet is based mainly
on grains and rice.
And if someone in the government
says, well, there's
a shortage of that.
Maybe you should supplement
more vegetables for it.
Then they aren't very
willing to switch.
PROFESSOR: One reason why your
information might be limited
is that even when you
get a source of
information from outside--
for example, the government--
tells you, you
should eat your vegetable.
You should eat these kinds of
cereals rather than those
kinds of cereals.
You should replace some rice
with pulses, or some rice with
cereals, people are reluctant
to do it.
And why would we think that
people are reluctant to follow
this information from
the government?
AUDIENCE: A bunch of reasons.
One might be a variety of foods
might not be available
in that region.
And also, a lot of those things
are more expensive.
So the cheaper things are very
carb-heavy things, which is
quite filling.
So you might not choose to go
with vegetables [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there are two reasons, two
possibilities in what you said.
The first one is a chicken
and egg problem.
Because if no one eats
spinach in a place--
and spinach is a great thing--
but if no one eats it, it's
just not available, and
therefore you cannot
try it out.
What was the second
one, excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The second one is
that the cheaper food is
generally more carb-heavy, and
so it's quite filling, and you
might choose to buy that over
vegetables which are much more
expensive than the
rest of the food.
PROFESSOR: Right.
And the second one could
be a matter of costs.
AUDIENCE: And I think that the
benefit of nutrient intakes
are over the long-term.
So if you're taking a small
iron tablet, the next day,
miraculously you're not going
to perform better.
But over the long-term,
you might see smaller
improvements.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it could be that if is
difficult to learn.
So for example, one thing that
could happen is that someone
from outside, very well-meaning,
say you should
really eat iron-fortified
flour instead of
your regular flour.
And you try.
And then, after one week, you
don't feel like Popeye.
It's not that things have
dramatically changed.
And in fact, if I put you on a
treadmill and I ask you to
perform an exercise,
I will know
that you are 10% stronger.
But this is not something--
if you are 10% stronger the next
month, are you going to
be able to really see the
difference or not?
So it might not be immediately
clear.
And if that is the case, then
you might have a situation
where people arrive from outside
and give you this
message, and say, you should
really change your
diet in this way.
And you make, maybe, an effort
to follow them for some time.
Spend a little bit more money,
or a little bit more effort
into going into pasturizing
your food.
And then it happens, and you're
not any stronger.
And you're like, whatever
did they tell me?
It's like, this is no better.
Because your expectations were
set high enough to encourage
you to do the switch.
And the problem is there would
be a tendency to slightly
oversell how much better
you're going to feel.
Which then is going to
translate into a
disappointment.
So one example of that is
something that people have
found in a deworming program in
Kenya, which we're going to
discuss in a moment.
So it's a charitable
deworming program.
Deworming is, in some sense, a
nutrition program, because the
worms are competing with
the kid for the food.
So by removing the worms, you
are increasing the amount of
food that stays with the kid.
I'm sorry, this is not a great
conversation to have right
after lunch.
But that's kind of the biology
of it, in two words.
So when you give deworming--
and we are going to see that
in a minute-- that
does make the kid--
that reduces anemia,
that reduces the
incidence of being sick.
That reduces, therefore,
absence from school.
So there was an NGO that was
trying to promote deworming in
some randomly-selected schools
in the late '90s, early 2000s.
And they went, and they
explained all of this with a
lot of energy, and said, your
kid is going to feel much
better, and is going to go to
school more, and all of that.
And parents had to sign
a form to agree
to get the kid dewormed.
So it's not money.
It's not a huge amount
of effort.
But it's still a little
bit of effort.
And also, you have to want it.
And people were interested--
the researches were interested
to know whether parents were
more likely to sign the form
if they knew more people
around them who got a chance
to get the deworming.
So because it was a randomized
experiment, which was done at
the level of the school--
I'm going to show you
a map in a moment--
some people got treated in some
schools, and some people
didn't get treated
immediately.
So people who are in a treated
schools may have had friends
who were in neighboring schools,
which may have been
treated a control.
So what the researchers did is
to look at whether you were
more likely to take up the
deworming once you got the
option if you had more
friends who got the
option the year before.
And their prior going into
this, was that the more
friends you have who got into
the deworming, the more you
are likely to do it yourself,
because you
will see the benefits.
And what they found was
exactly the opposite.
Which is the more friends you
had who had been a chance to
get dewormed a year before,
the less you are likely to
take up the deworming once
you got a chance.
And what are the possible
interpretations for that
somewhat weird results?
Yeah, Zach?
AUDIENCE: One possible
interpretation is that it
depends on how you
get the worms.
The fact that your friends are
being treated for you might be
less likely to get it, like
in the case of malaria.
If everybody in the community's
using the bednet,
you probably don't have to.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that's a first possible
interpretation, which is worms
are, in fact, highly
contagious.
So if most of your friends are
treated, then they probably
don't have worms anymore.
You might feel, well, I don't
need to go to the trouble of
getting dewormed because they
did, therefore there are fewer
worms around.
And there is some side effect.
Why would you take
the trouble?
Yeah, Norm?
AUDIENCE: Maybe people also,
since people get dewormed, and
then their problems decrease,
people don't think it's as
much of an issue, because
it's not as prominent.
So it's the externality just
decreasing, they just don't
realize that it's such
a big threat anymore.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So that could be
another thing.
Which is, people learn that--
So people say, oh, these other
kids got dewormed, but they
are not much healthier
than me.
And the fact is, you don't
realize that you are healthy
because they are healthy, and
they made you healthier.
So you are now comparing the
benefits of you as a control
child-- you are not
yet treated--
to the other kids
who got treated.
And the difference is
not that large.
It's not that large precisely
because of the contagion
effect that Zack mentioned.
But so you're trying to learn
the effect, and so it's not
that large.
And even if you don't understand
that it's due to
the externality, so you don't
do this calculation, saying,
it's not worthwhile.
You just see it and think,
what did they sell me?
This thing doesn't really
make any difference.
And so you decide not to do it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say
that, even if you don't really
have any change in your health
status, maybe the change that
the other people have is
not so great as to
convince you to get it.
You see that the medication
quote, unquote, doesn't work.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That also could be the case.
Could be that, even without
this mechanism--
which is a very nice one-- but
even without this mechanism,
you could see the other children
and say, well, first
thing, they got sick when they
ate the deworming pill.
So the side effect
is immediate.
It's getting worse and worse.
But as the worm dies, this make
you pretty unwell for an
hour or two, as your body
gets rid of them.
And then you get better.
But the side effect is salient
and immediate, and the
benefits are a little
bit less apparent.
And this, of course, is
reinforced by the
point that Norm made.
Which is that the externalities
make it
difficult to compare treatment
and control.
So for all of these reasons--
so this is one example of why
it's very difficult for people
to learn about relatively subtle
nutrition mechanisms.
And so what is happening with
deworming, that's maybe made a
little bit harder but the
externalities, which, A, gives
[INAUDIBLE]
like strategic reasons
not to do it.
So worms give Norms' difficulty
of learning
explanation.
But that's could also be at
play with iron pill, or
supplementing your
flour with iron.
Where you're like, really not
that much is. happening.
So these are possible reasons
why you wouldn't do what the
good man, or well-meaning
NGO tells you to do.
You don't have the
information.
Learning is difficult, because
the effects are subtle.
This implies spending
more money.
Nd maybe those foods are not
even available for you in a
convenient way.
What else could be going
on, potentially?
AUDIENCE: If the wages are set
wages, then even if you eat
more stronger, you're still
going to get the
same amount of money.
So there's no point in being
more productive.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So another possible explanation
is you could
realize that it's going
to make you a bit more
productive, but you might
wonder, what's the use of me
being more productive if, in
fact, the wages are not piece
wage but day wage?
And you are a little bit
more productive.
But you need to go and convince
your employer that
now I'm a little bit more
productive, so you need to pay
me more on a daily basis.
But your employer is not behind
your back, checking
what it is you're eating
every day.
And so your consumption is an
upsell from the point of view
of the employer.
But there is a more moral hazard
issue, where you could
go and say, I'm telling you
I've eaten so much.
I'm very strong.
You can monitor, you can see.
Unless your employer can really
be monitoring your
output in a very close way,
which might not always be
possible, then they might
say, whatever.
I'm just assuming that you
are the average person.
And there is one study that
shows that shows employers
recognize that taller people
are more productive.
Taller people usually have been
better fed, maybe, when
they grew up.
And they are stronger.
Taller, maybe stronger,
more muscles.
People are more productive,
they pay them more.
But how much you've eaten and
how well you've eaten
previously does not
affect wages.
And that is because that isn't
observed from the point of
view of the employer.
And if they can't see the
output either, it's
he said, she said.
How do I know you're actually
more productive?
So of course, the solution to
that would be for the employer
to feed people iron supplement
on the job.
And why they're not doing
that, I don't know.
But that would be an interesting
thing to consider.
Because then they could know.
They could say, yeah.
I can pay you a bit more, as
long as you are eating your
iron supplement.
So let's go to all of this in a
little more systematic way.
So the first thing we need to
check is, all of this learning
is going to be--
I think people are very
naturally associating more
calories with more strength.
Even we have this in
mind-- to a point,
until we eat too much.
But this is probably harder to
learn about-- micronutrient
deficiency.
Because that's not something
that is as obvious, and you
don't necessarily know
which foods have what
nutrients, et cetera.
And so the first thing we need
to establish is that
micronutrient deficiency
actually matters.
And in particular, that the poor
and even the not-so-poor
could become more productive if
they got more micronutrient
supplementation in their diet.
For that, of course, we could
compound the wages of people
who have more hemoglobin in
their blood and the wages of
people who have less hemoglobin
in their blood.
If we do that, what do you
think we will find?
Most likely?
We look at the data set, and we
look at the wages of anemic
people versus the wages
of non-anemic people?
Richard?
AUDIENCE: Of course, the
non-anemic people have more
strength to go to work, so their
wages are higher if they
are paid by the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the non-anemic
people, when we do this
comparison, will make
more money.
That's sure poverty in
every data set, we're
going to find that.
But once we find that, can we
for sure say it's the effect
of being anemic?
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily.
It could be environmental
factors.
You could be anemic because
you don't make [INAUDIBLE]
enough to have a proper diet,
or you could not have wages
because you're anemic.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there's two things.
So first, they could be a
reverse causality at play.
Which is, you could be anemic
because you don't own enough
to buy spinach.
That's one.
And what else could
be at play?
Even if we manage to shut down
this mechanism, or assume that
specific mechanism
is not there?
What could be other things
that would explain this
correlation between anemia
and [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: It might be
some other third
factor that causes both.
For instance, your social
status, perhaps, means you can
only get a certain
kind of job.
And it also means that it's
harder for you to get good
wages and then get
better diet.
PROFESSOR: Right.
There could be something
that explains both.
For example, your social status,
or for example, how
well-educated you are, or the
types of opportunities you
have access to.
Or anything like that would
both effect your
anemia and your wage.
So we don't know.
So that's something which is
actually relatively easy to
organize as a randomized
experiment, because you can
pretty much cure anemia, at
least temporarily, by giving
people iron supplements.
So that's almost like a medical
study you can give
some people.
So this was done in Indonesia.
The WISE stands for Work and
Iron Status Evaluation.
They
They worked with several
thousand households.
And they provided them with
either an iron supplement or a
placebo in a randomly-selected
way.
So they randomized
the household.
And once they pick a household's
treatment, they
give everyone in the household
the iron supplement.
It takes a few months for people
to absorb the iron and
to become iron-replete.
Once you're not anemic, you have
enough iron in your body,
you get rid of the rest.
So anemia is something which is,
either you are anemic or
you're not.
And once you're not-- that is,
once your hemoglobin is above
13 for men, and for women
it's between 11 and 12.
That's gram per deciliter.
You just stop absorbing it.
So what they found when they
gave this iron supplement is
that there is no effect of
comparing the people who got
the placebo and people who got
the pill if they were not
anemic before.
There is no impact on them.
That's exactly what you would
expect, because once you have
enough, you have enough.
There is nothing more
we can tell you.
On the other hand, the more
anemic you were before-- that
is, the further you were from
12 grams per deciliter of
hemoglobin in your blood--
the larger the effect, in
terms of the increase in
hemoglobin in your blood.
That is, what they found is that
the people who got the
supplement almost all got
to 12, or close to 12.
So the further away
you were from 12,
the bigger the effect.
And so, once they do that, they
can separately at people
who were anemic at baseline
and people who weren't.
And they found that if you
focus on people who were
anemic at baseline, and people
who were self-employed, those
people made substantially more
money after they received the
iron supplement.
So they looked at the wages
eight months after the iron
supplement starts.
And then there is another end
line a few months later.
And they find these people
to make more money.
So about $40 more per year.
Which is not nothing.
This is not an enormous
amount.
This is not a doubling of
the wage or anything.
The yearly wages of these people
may have been around
$500 or something like that.
So it's maybe a little less
than 10% increase.
But this is very cheap.
Because if someone wanted to--
well, actually the experiment
itself was very expensive.
Because they had to go behind
people's backs and make sure
that actually eat the pill.
And they had so many nurses,
and they were really
controlling that they were
following the protocol.
So for the experiment itself,
costs much more
than $40 per person.
But what they argue in their
paper is that that's not
really interesting, because if
someone wanted to do it, they
could just buy 45 fish sauce.
And that would cost
them only $6.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: In the experiment, do
they control for the fact
that people usually earn higher
wages as time passes?
So next year, my wage is
probably going to be higher
than this year, because I
have more experience.
It means I can get
a better wage.
I'm better at catching fish.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's an excellent point.
You're saying you would want to
control for the fact that
as time passes, you
earn more money.
So how would they be able to do
that in the context of this
experiment?
AUDIENCE: Maybe there's a
historical [INAUDIBLE].
I'd like to figure out how much
people would earn over
their lifetime in that region,
and then control for that
percentage.
And they can account-- maybe in
the $40 increase, there is
$22 into that that is perhaps
due to the [INAUDIBLE]
average increase in wages.
PROFESSOR: And so you're saying
what they could do to
control for an historical trend
is to try to find out
what the historical trend
would have been.
And in particular, what is in
their data that tells them
what the historical trend
would have been,
directly free of charge.
Not free of charge, because
that was in the design.
But once you have
the experiment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The control group.
PROFESSOR: The control group.
There is a placebo group.
So half the sample
gets nothing.
So what they actually do in the
experiment is they compare
the wage growth of people who
got the program to people who
got the placebo.
In fact, here they compare
the wage growth of the
self-employed people who were
anemic at baseline in the
treatment group and in
the control group.
And you are exactly right
that those wages
increase in both cases.
But they increased faster
in the treatment group.
And the $40 is the difference
in the growth.
So it's already accounting
for that.
So what I say is that, well, if
someone wanted to do it on
the own, that wouldn't cost
them so much money.
That would just cost them $6
per year for a gain of $40.
So this is a case where you
would think it's something
that starts looking
like an S-shape.
Which is, if you become rich
enough for spending an extra
$6, you actually get a return
which is much higher than $6.
So you may have this increasing
return that is
necessary for the poverty trap
to emerge, where the slightly
richer people get the fortified
fish sauce instead
of the regular fish sauce
that costs them $6, and
they make $40 extra.
So you could say, well,
there is something.
Except that, of course,
you have to ask.
$6 is not all that much, so what
is preventing these poor
people to pay $6?
So that is the first place
where, if we compare this, 40
to 6 is the first place where
we can see a poverty trap.
Except we'll have to explain
why it's there.
We'll have to explain why it
seems that the poor people are
less likely to spend the
$6 on fortified fish
sauce in their reach.
That's for adults.
So already, we saw that for
calories, we don't see such a
big return to calorie
consumption.
By for iron, we see it.
Now, another place where we do
see, potentially, very large
returns of investing into food
is when you're trying to
invest in the nutrition
of your children.
So why is it that, even
though if we're
talking about calories--
even more micronutrients,
but any kind of
investment in your children--
may have a larger impact
than the same
investment for an adult?
AUDIENCE: Because children are
still growing and developing.
Their brains are still growing,
and their bones.
Basically, the frame for who
their going to be is in
development at this point
in their life.
So it's important that they can
reach their potential by
giving them the nutrients
that they need now.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the first reason, pure health
reason, is that when
you're investing into a child's
nutrition, be it
calorie or micronutrient, you
don't only make the child more
productive tomorrow, you are
changing the adult that this
child is going to be.
You are making this person reach
their genetic potential
in terms of height, for example,
that they might not
otherwise be getting.
You are helping this
person reach that
potential in their brain.
You're helping this person
develop the muscles that they
would have gotten.
And some of these, you might not
be able to recover later.
In particular, some of the
nutritional deficiency that
you get as very small children,
in between weaning
at about six months and two
years, would be very easy to
catch up once the child's
actually gone.
Even once a child is
more than two.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's no access
to things like
education at this point.
So if they're better nourished
now, then they
can focus on that.
Versus an adult probably
wouldn't be thinking about
going back to school
at that point.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the second reason is that,
even if we forget this
biological phenomenon, the job
of a child is typically to be
in school, or to learn
things around them.
Not necessarily in school.
Some can be outside of school.
They are still getting all the
information in the world.
That's what children do.
And if you do this job better,
then you are building your
human capitol.
Really think of it as like, the
capitol of each of us is
our health, which is affected
by how much we eat directly.
But also what we know,
our experience, our
education, et cetera.
And if we do this job better
as children, we'll have a
better stock of education for
the rest of our lives.
Education and knowledge
generally.
And we are be going to get the
return from that every year.
So when we do our job better as
an adult, we earn a higher
wage and that's it.
When we do our job better at
your age, or even earlier,
when you were a child, when you
were a small child trying
to learn things, since your job
is to develop, that means
you're better developed.
AUDIENCE: Is it more important
to have good nutrition when
the mom's pregnant, or after
the child's born?
PROFESSOR: Both are important.
We're going to get to
the mom in a minute.
But both children are important,
and in utero is
very important.
Both of them are important.
So for these reasons, if you
take a child and you say, I'm
going to feed this child better,
if only between the
time of six months
to two years--
or let's say, even if you were
going from six months to ten
years, when they are in full
development of their body and
their mind.
I'm going to then, on
return, potentially,
for his entire life.
That means the size in
difference in investment in
how much you're going to get in
the future compared to the
investment you are making
is much, much larger.
And that can, again, give you
the potential for an S-shape.
Where a poorer person is going
to invest a little less.
And this difference at
this points can be--
this difference in slightly
smaller investment at critical
range could translate into much,
much smaller lifetime
earning for a child.
So let's see some examples
of that.
So the first one is the
deworming example that I was
talking about.
And this was done, also, in
a randomized experiment.
That's the one I was talking
to you about, where they
realized that the more people
you knew who took the
deworming, the less likely
you were to take it.
Well, it turned out that
was actually a mistake.
Because being dewormed
is extremely helpful.
So what I did is, this is the
region where they worked,
where you had a bunch
of schools.
This is a map.
You can see that the region
is close to Lake Victoria.
Worms, particularly
schistosomasis, is something
that you're much more likely to
get if you are walking in
the fresh water.
Particularly when it's
not that clean, but
when it's not salty.
So ones basically climb from the
sole of your feet inside.
So when these kids go fishing
in the lake, or just go hang
out in the lake, much more
likely to get worms.
So this region is infected
by worms.
About a quarter of the worm
children suffer from worms.
One thing with worms is that
they've never killed anybody.
At least, not these worms.
There are some worms
that gives you very
spectacular, big legs.
And those worms are a little
bit more fashionable.
But these little hookworm,
schistosomasis,
doesn't kill people.
You can't really see that
someone has them.
So as a reason, it's not a
disease that anybody's
particularly excited about.
I want to make you excited about
worms for about, like,
at least 15 minutes.
You can come back and say, well,
these worms, there is
something with them.
So the researcher went to this
area, and they separated to
schools into three
groups randomly.
Why did they pick the school?
Why did they decide to randomize
at the school level
instead of doing it
within school?
For example, if you remember
the bednet experiment, the
bednet experiment was done
at the individual level.
Here, they treated all the
children in the school.
All the children was
left as control.
Why did they decide to do
it at the school level?
Yup.
AUDIENCE: So kids may
affect one another.
So if one child in a classroom
is dewormed and the other is
not, they may be learning
better.
And because they're learning
better, the other child may
also be increasing their
understanding.
If you do it at a school level,
they can cancel out
that effect.
So they can compare schools
where all children are and
schools where all
children aren't.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So kids' education could
affect one another.
What else?
In what way could they also
affect one another?
AUDIENCE: Isn't there the
externality, because they're
very contagious, you said?
PROFESSOR: Right.
There is the direct deworming
externality that Zach and Noah
mentioned earlier.
Which is actually, worms
are hyper-contagious.
So if you compare, when they
have done randomized
experiments before within
schools, they were very
surprised, because they're
saying, we are deworming these
children, and we see no
effect on anything.
And the thing is, the control
kids were re-infecting the
treated kids, and the treated
kids were also making the
control kids less sick.
So the effect was zero.
So here, they decided, let's
go and randomize the at the
school level.
And the first thing they
did is that they
went into the schools.
So they did the school
in three groups.
They dewormed Group 1 in
'98-2003, and then dewormed
the Group 2 in 1999-2003,
and dewormed the
group three in 2001-2003.
So the Group 3 three children
got, on average, less two
fewer years of deworming
compared to the Group 1 and 2.
There was a first study they
did, which was they collected
data in 2000.
And in 2000, they compared
children in Group 1 and 2 to
children in Group 3.
So children in Group 1 and 2 had
been treated either one or
two years, and children
in Group 3 had not
being treated yet.
And what they found at this time
was children, of course,
were less likely to have worms
if they had been dewormed.
Otherwise, it's not much
study to talk about.
Number one is children who had
been dewormed [INAUDIBLE],
they are less likely
to be anemic.
And importantly, they are less
likely to miss school.
So they find that there was
an increase of about 15%.
So 1/6 of a year in
participation in school.
So what this study that we are
doing now does is that it's
tracking the children who were
in primary school at this time
later when they go up.
So the date we're going to
look at is in 2007-2009.
So a kid who was 10 in 1998 is
now 20, and is therefore
usually doing something,
working.
And therefore, they can start
looking at whether these
people are now earning
more money.
So it's a big project, because
these children have gone all
over the place.
So they have had some difficulty
finding them.
One of them was in London, and
they went and interviewed a
person in London.
Many of them had moved to
Nairobi or had moved to
Mombasa or had moved
to Uganda.
So what they did is they did a
first wave of it where they
tried to track everyone.
And they found about
60% of the people.
And that's not enough, because
the 40% you don't find might
be the ones that have
the bigger effect.
They might be the one that have
moved to London, because
of the extra education
they are getting.
So then they decided, let's take
a smaller number of kids,
and track them wherever
they are.
Really find them.
And when you do that,
they found a quite a
large number of them.
So that altogether in the
sample, they have about 85% of
tracking rate, in
treatment and in
controls very similarly.
So therefore, we can now look
at what happened to wages.
So this is the empirical
distribution of log wages.
So what this tells you
is, roughly, if you
take any line here--
for example, it says
log earning of 7.
So wages tend to
be log numbers.
So we like to show logs.
So in the treatment group,
about 10% of
people, a log of 7.
And in the control group,
that's about 21%, 25%,
something like that.
So what does this mean?
This What happened to the
distribution of wage between
treatment and control, and
what does this mean?
How do we read this?
You can do it.
You've seen a distribution,
any distribution before.
I know that.
Just describe what happens
to these two curves.
You, you, you, you.
I was talking to you.
Just describe what happens
to these two curves.
Just tell me, physically, what
happens to these two curves.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It moved right.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Right?
That was hard.
They moved right.
Now, what is hard is saying,
well, now that they move
right, what does this mean?
Noah.
AUDIENCE: Well, I think
two things.
Well, first of all, the on
average peaks higher, which
means that the distribution in
any case, on average, people
[INAUDIBLE].
And also, it looks like it's
narrower, which means that
more people are also earning
more, as opposed to just the
average also earning more.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So those two things
are exactly true.
So what we see is, number
one, here is the peak.
So this is where, in the control
group, we get 45% of
people earning about
a wage of 8.
That's the mode of
the distribution.
Then, the nice thing with wages
is they're going to be
log normal, which means that the
mode is about the medium.
It also means that 50% of the
people in the control group
earn less than 8.
Whereas here, we find that, if
we want to find 50% of the
people earning less than
something, it's closer.
So for the control group, it's
like 7 and 1/2, and the
treatment group is 8.
So in the control group, 50% of
people earn less than 7 and
1/2, and in the treatment
group, 50% of people
earn less than 8.
And in fact, we could transform
this graph into a
cumulative distribution function
instead of density.
And we would find that, given
this graph, given that it's
nicely shifted to the right
and it's also a little bit
less valuable, as Noah pointed
out, we would find that at
every percentage, we have more
people in the control group
who make less than that
at every level.
We have a more people in the
control group earning less
than that than in the
treatment group.
Which means that--
Well, it has to mean that
the people in the
treatment group earn more.
And not only that, but--
not every single person,
but statistically--
everybody in the treatment
does somewhat better.
So we are saying the
distribution in the treatment
group statistically dominates
the distribution in the
control group.
If you had to choose which
society to live in, without
knowing, you would pick
the treatment group.
Because the chance that you are
earning more is better in
one place than the other.
So that's what happens with
this distribution.
We can just look at them and
say, yeah, we have more people
earning less and we have here
more people earning more.
So now we can say, well,
how does it look like?
This could just all be nice
in graph, but there is no
standard error here.
There is no confidence
interval.
Maybe this is not really
very solid.
So we can look at that
in a regression.
So this is a simple regression,
which gives us
directly the difference--
what you can read here is the
difference between the log
earning of the treatment group
and the log earning of the
control group.
That means I could have plotted
bar charts like we had
with the bednet.
It's saying, this is
the mean here.
The mean wage in the control
group is 7.8, which
corresponds to above the median
and above the mode of
the distribution, 7.8.
And the mean wage for the
treatment group is log.18.
So that means about 18--
19, sorry.
19 percentage points higher
than the mean in
the treatment group.
So when we run regression in
logs, the advantage is we can
read the coefficient
directly as the
percentage point increases.
So if we wanted to know, what's
the mean log wages in
the treatment group?
What do we need to do
from this graph?
So make sure that you
have it well.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Take the median
and multiply it by 1.19.
PROFESSOR: No.
So what you would do--
This is the mean of the log.
And this is the log point
that they get.
So if we wanted to know the log
wages for the treatment
group, all we would need to
do is to add 0.19 to 7.8.
So that would be about 8.
And then if we wanted to know
the level then we would take
the exponential of 8.
Right?
So when you have experiments,
you can just take the mean,
and you can calculate the mean
in the treatment group or the
mean the control group.
But in the papers in studies,
what you generally see is
people running a very simple,
ordinary [INAUDIBLE] square
regression on wages of whether
you are a treatment person.
And the way we'll read this is
just saying, this is the
difference between treatment
and control.
And this is the mean
for control.
And then, once we've done that,
we can add other things
that absolves the noise,
and we'll get
slightly different results.
But not very different,
because everything is
randomized.
What is this one?
Over here?
What is this little
[INAUDIBLE]
in [INAUDIBLE]?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Errors?
PROFESSOR: The standard error.
Exactly.
This guy is the standard
error.
So this is saying there is some
noise around these wages.
So the difference, the mean,
because we have the
distribution of wages.
So there is some variation
around the estimate.
And therefore, there is some
noise around our estimate of
the difference between treatment
and control wages.
And that tells us the
standard error.
So now we need to know, well,
how do I know whether this
effect is just due to chance,
or if it's a real effect.
Once I give you the
coefficient, and
the standard error.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If it's more than two
standard errors, isn't it
significant?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you divide the coefficient
by the standard
error, it gives you something
we call the t-statistic.
For the hypothesis that
the effect is 0.
So when we divide the
coefficient by the standard
error, we get the t-statistic,
and the t-statistic is for the
test that the coefficient
is not 0.
So the hypothesis is, is
this coefficient 0?
So each test goes with a level
of confidence, which is the
probability of a
type one error.
That is, the probability that
you are saying there is an
effect when in fact,
there is not.
Generally in economics--
I don't know in other fields,
but in economics-- generally
we go with sizes of 5%.
So we accept to say that
something has an effect when
in fact it doesn't with
a probability of 5%.
And 5% corresponds to a
t-statistic of 1.96.
So when you see regression table
like this, it's very
simple if things
are randomized.
When you see a regression,
looking at these effects,
gives you the difference
between treatment and control.
Divided by it's standard
error.
And if it's above 1.96, it tells
you that the effect is
significantly different
from 0.
That is, there is
a real effect.
Not an effect due to chance.
So here of course, it's
much above 2.
And it's about 19%.
So it tells you that the wage
of the treated guys is 19%
higher than the wage of
the control guys.
Which is a fair amount.
So why do I say that
19% wage is high?
What was the economic growth
in Kenya over this period,
give or take?
An order of magnitude?
AUDIENCE: 10%?
PROFESSOR: 10% would be nice.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I don't know if they
had any single year where
they had 10% growth.
AUDIENCE: Like 4?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, 3 4.
3, 4.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
what inflation is?
PROFESSOR: So that would
be in real time.
AUDIENCE: Adjusted.
All right.
PROFESSOR: But this is,
remember, we are comparing
treatment to control.
So there is no inflation here,
because our treatment people
were measured at
the same time.
Take real growth.
If we are saying 3% to 4% a
year, we are being generous to
Kenya for the average.
So that means that these guys
got the equivalent of several
years of good economic growth,
except there has not been many
years in Kenya where there has
been several years of good
economic growth.
So that's why I wanted to get
you excited about worms for
five minutes.
So this thing corresponds to
giving the kids a pill which
costs about, including the
delivery cost and all of that,
about $0.60 of delivering
the pill.
You need to do that
twice a year.
And this is a difference between
doing it for three
years versus one.
So this is your investment,
it's probably a good
investment, that was delivered
by society here in the form of
this NGO, was a [INAUDIBLE].
And that's 19% per year.
That's a lot.
Even people, if they are to do
it themselves, maybe they have
to do to the shop so they
don't get it for $0.60.
They have to pay $1.
Then they get several years of
good growth for the entire
lifetime of the child.
So we are talking about, for
a lifetime [INAUDIBLE]
of several thousand dollars
of extra wages.
And we can see it here.
So what this is is these are
the benefits that you're
getting from this 19% increase
in earnings.
So imagine that you get 19%
increase in earnings.
Take the GDP of Kenya, or the
average wage level of Kenya.
Multiplied by 19%.
That's how much you're
getting every year.
Then you have to compute
the net present value.
Because the benefit that you're
getting if you have to
pay the investment today, but
you're starting to get the
return when you're 20 and then
over your lifetime, it's not
as valuable.
So we are using some
[INAUDIBLE], let's say 5%.
And we are computing the net
present value of those
earnings, like we would for
the investment in a stock.
So when you do that, you get
over $1,000 increasing in your
lifetime earnings.
So this is that.
And this is how much it cost.
So you need to deliver the
pills, $0.65 per year, and
then they wanted to--
so that would be a huge benefit
of, like, $1,500 or
$1,100 divided by $0.65.
That would be pretty gigantic.
That's why worms are exciting.
Well, they don't want to make
it too exciting, so they are
saying, well, let's see what all
the costs we need to add.
Well, these kids have gone to
school a little longer.
They've gone to school
more every year.
So while in school, they are not
playing, or they are not
earning some wage.
So they are making some
assumption of what is this
opportunity cost.
Other wage, unskilled wage.
All of the day they spend
in school, they
assign them the wage.
That's an over-estimate, because
usually the kids are
just doing nothing, because
they are sick.
So this is being very
generous for the
cost of being in school.
And then, they also add the
fact that if you have more
kids in school, you need to
have, maybe, a little bit more
teachers and all that.
So they also can create
how much that can be.
So these things, you might want
to put them, or you might
not want to put them.
But the bottom line is that when
you do that, this bar is
pretty huge, and this bar
is pretty minimal.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If they're so clear,
why doesn't Kenya's government
support it?
PROFESSOR: Well, the
answer is they do.
Because until this study, it
wasn't so obvious that the
benefits are so large.
Because how would you know?
You only had those experiments
where you were comparing
people within the same school.
And you found no effect
of deworming.
So this study came.
That's an interesting political
economic story.
This study came-- the first one,
not even the second one.
And showed that it basically
costs nothing
to put kids in school.
The cheapest way to
get kids to attend
to school more regularly.
So the researchers and us here
at Poverty Action have started
to advertise this as, you might
not have thought it that
way, but deworming is
the cheapest way
to get kids in school.
We went to Davos.
Davos is this world congress
of rich people.
And we presented this kind of
data, and showed to them, you
know what, you might not think
deworming is so exciting, but
in fact it is.
Because it's a great
investment.
So they kind of liked
the idea.
Well, we started
an organization
called deworm the world.
And started just diffusing
these kind of results.
We didn't even have the
wage results yet.
It was just education results,
saying, deworming is a
sensible education policy.
It's a very cheap way to
get kids in school.
And started working with the
government to get this
information out.
One complicated thing with
deworming from a political
economic point of view is that
it's a health program that you
want to do in school.
The reason why you want to do
it in school is you have all
the kids there.
That's why it's cheap.
But when you want to do a health
program in school, you
need the Health Ministry and
the Education Ministry to
collaborate, or you need the
Finance Ministry to tell
them, you do it.
So that takes some effort,
but that effort got done.
And in fact, in Kenya they are
now deworming everywhere.
So that's millions, millions
of children.
And then this is also
moving up and down.
They're going to start doing it
in Bihar, which is a state
in India where they also
have a lot of worms.
They have started doing it in
Andhra Pradesh, where there is
not that many worms, but they
have subregions in Andhra
Pradesh with a lot of worms.
And in this way, the information
gets out, and
progressively it's taken up.
AUDIENCE: In Kenya, did the
government sponsor the
deworming program, or was
it outside donors?
PROFESSOR: In Kenya, the
answer is yes and no.
The direct answer is yes, but
it is subsidized in part by
the Fast Track Initiative, which
is international money
that government can access to do
things that help education.
So Kenya can elect to use Fast
Track Initiative money to do
textbooks, or to do computers
in school, or to do
blackboards, or to pay
teachers more.
And what they did is
they took some of
that money to do deworming.
The thing is, deworming is cheap
enough that once you
realize that it is a good thing
to do, money is less the
issue than getting everybody
on board and organized.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so I'm thinking
there's probably other
developing countries that have
significantly worm issues.
And then why aren't those
countries doing it?
You mentioned India, but I'd
imagine there's a lot more.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the answer is slowly, slowly
they are getting into
the bandwagon.
But that's a very good question,
which is, number one
you need to have the
evidence out.
And until fairly recently,
in particular until this
experiment, the evidence
wasn't out.
And this is not something
that people could just
make up on their own.
I think in particular, the
effect on education, I don't
think the first thing that
comes to an education
minister, or the first thing
that would come to you, if I'd
asked you in principle, how
would you increase education?
What's the cheapest
way to do it?
I don't think deworming would
have been very high on your
radar screen.
It's not very high on anybody's
radar screen,
precisely because worms
don't kill.
So people think of HIV as being
important, which it is.
But people don't
think of worms.
So that's the first reason.
Once the information is out,
then it needs to be
percolated.
People need to absorb It.
And I think this is happening,
actually.
This is one of the pretty
hopeful stories, in terms of
that the evidence can
make a difference.
AUDIENCE: I can understand
where you argue with
government about education
effects,
especially in children.
But when you get something
as long as wage
effects, pretty long time.
Are you assuming that no other
health hazards would offset
the gains which can be obtained
from deworming.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the question is whether I'm
assuming that there are no
other things that will happen.
And the beauty of this is I'm
not assuming anything.
In fact, I didn't.
But Ted Miguel and Michael
Kremer dewormed
the children in 1999.
And then they had the foresight
of deciding, we need
to continue to track them to
find out whether or not there
is a wage effect.
If you want to know my prior
when they started this
exercise, very honestly, is that
you're wasting your time.
All of these other things
will be happening.
You're never going to
find an effect.
And so when this came up, I
was very surprised in a
positive way.
But these results were not
even used to sell the
deworming to the government,
because we didn't have them
till very recently.
Only the education results
were used,
which are very immediate.
But the point here, you see,
you don't assume anything.
Whatever things would have
happened, happened.
And surprisingly,
didn't offset.
That's what the standard
error tells you.
So deworming is an interesting
policy, because it's a good
policy that's not
obviously good.
So it is nobody's
first choice.
So you have to make it people's
The evidence plays a role,
and then some convincing.
And what is interesting is that
the parents themselves,
they could do with
them as well.
And so the second question we
want to ask, which is the
individual version of
the same, why don't
government do it?
Is why don't parents do it?
Which is the same question
as, why don't people
buy the fish sauce.
We'll get to it in a moment,
we'll collect the thing.
Unless you want to have a--
AUDIENCE: For deworming, could
you just treat the water that
the children walk in, so that
the worms don't go in the
water, so the kids
won't get worms.
PROFESSOR: So the question is,
could you treat the water
instead of treating the kids?
I think that's an excellent
idea, because you could do it.
Except that Lake Victoria
is really big.
So I think for Lake Victoria it
would be a bit difficult.
It's really, really big.
It's almost like a freshwater
sea in the middle.
AUDIENCE: It's not just
a lake, right?
It's also puddles and
things like that.
People walking through
there with no shoes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's any body of fresh water
that creates the problem.
So that's general nutrition.
There are other examples of
effective [INAUDIBLE]
of nutrition.
But now let's skip to the
third one, which is the
nutrition in the womb, which
is what you were asking.
Whether it's not even more
important to feed
the pregnant woman.
And the answer is that it is.
So there is a doctor in the UK
called Dr. Barker who this
hypothesis has his name.
It's called the Barker
Hypothesis.
What he found is that basically,
he found that the
region which had the highest
child mortality, infant
mortality, neo-natal mortality,
were also the
places where people, once they
were born, had the lowest life
expectancy.
And he concluded that this was
a sign that your condition of
life in utero were
really important.
Of course, that was not
convincing at all, because the
regions that have the highest
infant mortality also are
pretty bad in many
other respects.
And you will expect that these
people live less long.
But still, he's the first one
who formulated the hypothesis.
And despite the fact that his
evidence was weak for it, the
hypothesis was right, as we
subsequently discovered.
I'm going to give you a few
examples where it was seen
very clearly.
One of the big names in this
is an economist at Colombia
named Doug Almond.
And the first thing that Doug
Almond found is that he looked
at people who were born just
after 1918, which is the
period where there was a big,
big flew epidemic in the US.
So many people died
of the flu.
Adults died of the flu.
But many people didn't,
and still had it.
And in particular, a lot of kids
were born from moms who
had had the flu.
And the paper here was very
simple, which was to compare
the life outcomes of people who
were in utero during the
period of the flu.
He doesn't even know whether
their mother had the flu.
It just makes it quite likely
that their mother had the flu
if they were born during
that period.
And they found that children who
were in this period during
the big flu pandemics were
sicker as adults.
They were more likely to have
all sorts of diseases.
Name a disease, they have it.
Or they are more likely
to have it.
They were earning less money.
They were less likely to
have gone to college.
And they died earlier,
they died younger.
So that was one of
the first people.
So particularly if your mom had
the flu when you were in
utero, that's not good.
That's not nutrition.
Other effects--
still a paper by Doug Almond--
is that people who are born
during or just after the
Chinese famine--
or even just after is
a better number.
Children who are born just after
the Chinese famine, so
who were in utero during
the famine, they of
course live less long.
They are shorter.
They have lower wages.
And even the children of the
children of these people are
shorter and doing less
well in life.
So there is even a second
generation that's let's
productive, fertile,
et cetera if you
were born in the famine.
There is, of course, a bias in
this, when we look at the
children who were born just
after the famine.
Which comes from what?
AUDIENCE: They probably also
experienced ramifications of
the famine afterwards.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it was afterwards.
The famine was very brutal,
and ended and
started very brutally.
So we might expect that there
is not so much effect after.
That but on the other hand,
what do you expect happens
during the famine?
AUDIENCE: Probably disease.
PROFESSOR: A lot of diseases
in particular.
A lot of adults died.
We are talking about 59
million adults dying.
And a lot of people probably
were never born.
And in particular, there were
stillborns or miscarriages.
So the people who made it
despite the fact that they
were in utero doing this period,
the babies who managed
to get born are probably pretty
good genetic potential
to start with.
And despite that, they are doing
much less well in life.
So there is a bias, but it goes
in the direction of not
finding an effect
of the famine.
Because surviving during the
famine already indicates that
you're a pretty feisty child.
So that's quite extreme.
You would say, yes, of course
being in utero during a famine
is a bad idea.
You should avoid it at
all costs if you can.
But maybe it's not particularly
relevant.
Because after all, we are not
talking about famine for most
poor people.
We are talking about
malnutrition and
ill-nutrition.
So here is one example
of that.
Is that children who were in
utero during Ramadan--
and Ramadan shifts, so it's
not a particular season.
So we can look at kids who were
in utero doing Ramadan
who were born in September, who
were born in October, who
were born in December.
All over the year.
This is a paper that
looks at Uganda.
Children born of Muslim mothers
and who were in utero
during Ramadan, in particular
in the first trimester of
pregnancy during the Ramadan,
are less educated.
It's many less educated and
earn less as adults.
And with Ramadan, it's not even
that you are not eating.
You're not eating
during the day.
But people eat during
the night.
But these long periods of
fasting are no good.
That's interesting, because
you don't have to observe
Ramadan when you're pregnant.
You could not do it.
And if you're really observant,
in fact, you have
the option of not doing
it and doing it later.
But pregnant women tend to do
Ramadan anyway because other
people around them do it.
And what is interesting here
is that, in terms of policy
implication, it could be
encouraged to say, you can not
observe the Ramadan.
Not everybody does it because
it's acceptable not to observe
it, potentially.
But most women do.
And this is not good
for their children.
And even though it's not
something massive, it's this
shift in the consumption.
The calories probably stay
relatively constant.
Another example-- which, again,
is nothing extreme--
the paper by Erica Field and
Maximo Torero, which looks at
one particular micronutrient,
which is iodine.
So iodine deficiency in
adulthood create this thyroid
insuffiency, so it makes
you a bit slow.
So in French, the expression
"cretin" comes from that.
In French, we say "cretin of the
Alps," because people from
the Alps were very
far from the sea.
So their salt came from the
mountain, not from the sea.
So it wasn't iodized.
So you had more thyroid
problems due to iodine
deficiency in the Alps
and elsewhere.
So now, iodized salt is
available on a large scale.
But before that, when it was
not available on a large
scale, at some point governments
realized this
problem and tried to
have programs of
distribution of iodine.
And what these people look at is
they look at the program in
Tanzania, which attempted to
reach every pregnant woman,
but failed.
So some kids, normally
you would have five
waves of the program.
A pill is sufficient
for several months.
So they were attempting to reach
people frequently enough
that all the pregnant woman
would have a pill covering
them for the duration
of the pregnancy.
But they failed to do that
because they were not
particularly organized.
So in some districts they went
in sometimes, and some
district they went in
some other times.
So what you can look is kids who
were lucky enough to be in
utero when their mother
was covered.
Compared to kids who were not
lucky, and who where in utero,
in particular first
trimester, when
their mom was not covered.
And what they look at is
education down the line.
And they found that the covered
kids have about a
third of a year more education
than the uncovered kids, for
receiving this iodine
supplementation.
So again, a pretty small
intervention makes a big
effect down in life.
So all of these create potential
for poverty traps,
because if the poor--
these are investments that
are not costly and
that have high return.
Even micronutrients for adults,
childhood pregnancy,
in this order.
You are asking, pregnancy is a
very short period of time.
Then it will affect the child
for their entire life.
So if the poor are less likely
to undertake the investment,
then there is a potential
for a poverty trap here.
So is it the case that the poor
are likely to undertake
this investment?
And the answer is yes.
Most of the poor still
consume a diet that's
very poor in Iran.
The vast majority of the
quarter of the world's
children who should get worms
are still not dewormed.
The WHO estimates that
40% of pregnant women
worldwide are anemic.
Not all of that is due continue
to iron deficiency
anemia, but probably
at least a half.
So these are three examples of
saying, these investments are
not undertaken, even though they
are potentially highly
productive.
And so you are saying, well,
maybe it's not undertaken, but
it's not because of poverty.
So is money an issue?
And it does seem to be that a
very small cost, even a very
small cost, seems to
discourage people.
Asking the question that
you were asking before.
At the level of government.
If 45 fish sauce costs only $6,
it seems the investment is
worthwhile, and yet no
poor family does it.
In Kenya, in the deworming
program, in the first group of
schools, at some point
the NGO wanted to do
the sustainable thing.
And the sustainable thing was
to ask people to cost-share.
So they had to pay a little
fee for their children.
Small fee for the
entire family.
And this is believed to
be help maintaining
the program, et cetera.
The moment where they introduced
the cost sharing,
the take up of the program
went to zero.
Nobody took it up.
So that goes back to this.
They didn't know the
effect, maybe.
Interestingly, it means asking
people to pay is not
sustainable.
Because it's the costlier thing
about the deworming
program is to drive your
car to the place.
So once you're there,
you want to do all
many people as possible.
So if the take up falls down to
zero, you've really lost a
lot of chances.
Another example.
It's not only money.
The thing is that it's not only
money that is the problem.
So it's not only poverty,
as in lack of income.
Because in India, we tried
something so to fight anemia.
We said, OK, fine.
People are not going
to buy iron pills.
But let's introduce a program
where the local miller who
mills the grain of everyone,
will add the iron.
But we only had money to install
the machine and pay
the miller to do it for
one minute a village.
And what we saw is that--
so people who were already
walking with that miller
continue to do so.
But the other people
didn't switch.
So the people who happened
to be close by
benefited from the program.
But no one was willing to work
the extra five minutes to
benefit from the program.
And moreover, the miller thought
it was a lot of effort
to add the iron.
So even though the rules were
you're supposed to do it
unless the family asks, they
switched to do the opposite,
which is you're supposed--
they wouldn't not do it if
the family didn't ask.
And the family didn't
really ask.
They didn't say no, but
they didn't say yes.
To the [INAUDIBLE], which was
very high at the beginning
when the miller did it by
default, it progressively went
to a very low number, and
the program collapsed.
Which suggests that it's
not only money,
it's any form of costs.
Which brings to these
other issues.
One is what Steve said earlier,
which is are the
workers going to reap the
benefit, or is the employer
going to reap the benefit?
And one sign that it might be
the employer rather than the
worker is that in Indonesia,
it's only the wages of the
self-employed that increased.
Not the wages, the
earnings of the
self-employed that increased.
The wages of people working
for a wage didn't go up.
In Kenya, it was different.
But in Kenya there is all
this education effect.
And one thing that we have
in Kenya is that
people switch sectors.
The young kids just started
workings in different sectors
altogether.
But for adults, it's
too late for them.
They're just going to do the
same thing a little better.
And they are not really
rewarded for that.
The other thing are the
information things we
discussed earlier.
It's very difficult to find out
on your own what makes a
difference and what doesn't.
Is it iron?
How do you know that
iron matters?
Until recently, scientists
didn't know.
In the '70s and '80s, scientists
were still
convinced that the big
problem was proteins.
And protein is a problem.
But they didn't think of
micronutrients as an issue.
So number one, the information
is very difficult to acquire.
So you need to trust outsider.
It's not very clear you
would trust them.
Finally--
and I will finish on that--
is that consumption
is a decision.
And people are not machines.
So they are not maximizing their
productivity, they are
maximizing their utility.
And their utility is made
of other things than our
productivity can be.
There is the food that you
have to eat every day.
And if you don't like it,
then this is horrible.
Because eating is the only thing
that we are doing day
in, day out.
So if we don't like to eat,
then it's kind of awful.
And in particular, this may
be one reason why it's
particularly difficult to have
people switch their diet.
This is something
where this is so
ingrained into our habits.
And if we are used do eating
in a particular way, we may
know that the best way is to eat
something else, but we may
be very reluctant to switch.
Now, this is a pattern that we
are seeing of course in this
country, as well as
anywhere else.
The second thing is you may care
about your social status.
Which might be related to how
big a party you throw for your
son's birthday or for your
daughter's wedding, or even
for your dad's funeral.
Which may be related to some
goods you may want to have,
like a TV or things like that.
People can care deeply about
these things, which may mean
that they decide to forego
nourishing their [INAUDIBLE]
to make sure that they can
actually do the things.
It's not like--
and finally, to diversity
of goods you have.
Like cell phones,
TVs, et cetera.
And all of that means that it
has very important policy
implications, of course.
Because it means that it's
not going to be trivial.
It's going to eventually be
quite difficult to get people
to convince to switch the
type of their diet.
And also, because of what we saw
last time, it's not such a
great idea to try and
subsidized grains
or things like that.
Because it's not going to
lead to an improvement.
It's not so much of the quantity
of food, because it's
not that useful to it more.
Nor in the quality of food,
because it's not the fasting
people will want to do with
the extra income.
That means that you would want
to do things that have a
chance directly to affect
the quality of the
food people are eating.
And in particular, children and
pregnant woman are eating.
So one is making it as
easy as possible to
do the right thing.
So invent foods that people
want to eat, but the
micronutrients is in them.
So there is something called
golden rice, which is rice
which is already fortified
in iron.
But that's GMOs, we might
like that or not.
But it's also like hybrids
foods, like yams, which are
very rich in vitamin A that
can grow in Africa.
So there are organizations
that work on this.
So the organizations that work
on this bioengineering--
like HarvestPlus, these types
of organizations--
historically have been focused
on making the food more
productive.
And what is needed is a shift
to making the food
higher-quality from the point
of view of nutrition.
And this is happening,
but slowly, slowly.
Other thing is when you have the
kids, you should invest in
the quality of their food.
Because the parents might not
know or might not do it.
But you have the kids right
in front of you.
So it's easy to do.
So deworming.
Make the school meal nutritious,
for example, by
sprinkling micronutrient
on them.
And the parents are not going
to compensate for that by
giving them less, because
they have no idea what
you're doing anyway.
And then you can think
of other things.
I'm going to let you move now.